[Musik]
kein schnee was
macht kaiser haben einige noch das
heroin spiel bestritt und bei anruf mord
bis
weihnachten
am schluss
sein
also habe einen raschen menschen mit
allem aber ich rede zur panikmache 4 5 6
7 8 10
[Musik]
ich bin dritte team zur wawel training
mit vorbereitet auf alles klasse dass
ich mittendrin
herzlich willkommen im camp
rostig verkündet so ist das buch genannt
was denken
sie genau haben sie schlug vor im wald
wild wind wesentlich ganz was tolles
priorität wir bleiben auf dem planeten
schutz von klima welche +15 trocken
reichlich auffangen und durch höhere und
damit
zur medizin und je nach möglichkeit ihre
eigentliche unterkunft wohnen hier zwei
nach der vertrieb laufe
die unterkunft kurz bauer und dich
zweiter brief zeit nämlich regen voraus
beste voraussetzungen für zwei nicht
unter freiem himmel
ein langes stammten zwei jahre fixiere
auf buch nabenhöhe vor dem worin soll
schlafe das ist basis von magento
einfach der nutzer stellen könnt auf
haben mit einer genau ziehen
aber so die jetzt einzug
perfekt je größer mich umso mehr
material buch zweimal bin ich mit 150
recht
genau macht genau richtig geil die
schotten gott herr steht daher was
gepostet wieder machen und so geht es
eine sonderbauzone herrscht ja super
schofield doch nicht klappt muss ich
jetzt
also 100 prozent sagen würde ich bin
einfach sagt stand ich mal verschiedene
sache aber als
hauptübel styler habe ich was ich
eigentlich zu dem thema braucht
viele verschiedene ist auch rainer sich
zu meine unabhängigkeit
wirklich alles reine sauber zu machen
ohne irgendwie zivilisations hilfsmittel
und darunter automatisch wann das
unabhängigkeit dank natur und dann frau
das buch finanzmittel aber was man alles
beachten was muss ich lerne
ja wir sind ein teil von der natur und
an das aber doch irgendwie gestiegen 8
davon entfernt und das ist audrey
patrick siben dann hat sich das danach
soll er jetzt sind die anderen unterwegs
gewesen
alle gut unterwegs oder
helmut simon der sozialarbeiterin über
der pharmaunternehmer bis zum
kriminalpolizist die ein teures
abenteuer anderem ein vorbereitet sie
wenn der ernstfall tritt
die hüter nach war die patrizia ist
therapeutin afar ursprünglich aus
valencia in spanien
einfach immer aus der komfortzone raus
gehen und etwas neues machen und ich hab
noch nie gezählt das turnier zählt sagt
nein als angst ob sport oder gruppen ja
also angst ich ja ich musste mir das
lange überlegen ich hab dann gedacht ja
also ich hab mich angemeldet aber so
inoffiziell reserve mir mal ein platz
nation doch ausdruck genau und ich
schreibe das hat niemandem davon erzählt
nicht mal meine liebsten
wenn die abwehr bringt berufe oder sehr
schlau und
endrunde mühsams detail mindestens ein
halber liter laut moses traf nur so wird
ihr
kurz bevor es ganz dunkel ich werde
endlich fertig
zieht zum probeliegen
juli war dass ich deine hand im schnee
gelegen
das sind so riesenschnecken und
leitet so im bett jetzt wirklich nicht
wer
interesse
jetzt kommen sie da war vielleicht
aber er ist mir zwar
harry wird bezweifelt ruhig
zu und
ließen ihm statt für die stark im boden
hier steht
und noch hat und umgekehrt darüber
stecke aber natürlich im spiel drin wenn
dann halt weniger vor dass knackte nicht
alle gemächlich los ist wenn man so will
der antiken und jugendbücher skorpion
ganz wichtig oder dass da möglich zb nur
umgekehrt
dank an luca hammer show es für die
normale leben isarstraße
politischer fischer und autofan
übernachtet er regelmäßig
ja ich sage mal ganz ganz wenig
grundkenntnisse und
wie sehr wirkungsvoll
warum
mit center als limit 40
wer mit dem heutigen programm mir würde
das murren da am 8 am morgen machten zu
tee und kaffee tafel und dem programm
weiter machen
aber
das ist noch nicht der moment um die
bewilligung
aber immerhin hedge fonds müssen schon
sie im kanister wasser es überlebe
zweite priorität essen und das
[Musik]
lässig war schmid und 80 metern uhren
der marke selber bald die welt berühren
max mutzke
[Musik]
der erste morgen im sommercamp
mcqueen
war
ja und der ist auch noch hinter
gut
mit ferrari ist die nachtruhe
hab ich geschlafen
ich bin wirklich wie hektisch nach der
herz für sich merken jede kleinigkeit
oder vielleicht
nicht
aber
er glaubte erst nachtisch immer
geschenkt die zweite als werden
vielleicht jetzt meinen mann zu hause
gehen und sagen
uns morgens liter
und ein grab stock schnitzel zum keine
wurzeln ausgraben damit
wie sackmesser grund das in grenzen
leben reißt ihnen muss er braucht
meister mit feststehender klinge dieser
gewässer zum schnitzen und holzspalter
ja so gut
danke
ich bin ich noch erstreckt sollen sich
sehr gründlich steuer
telefonierten oder
amüsant finde
dass du schon alles erlebt punkte sowie
überlebenskampf falschparker sind
wirkliche situation psychiatrie karte
sind die erste wirklich heftig an die in
mexiko guatemala
wo man mit ehrgeiz und wachsen sind wo
dann guck mal wie es mit
die heimische volk stattgefunden hat und
dass ich danach wieder ans licht wurde
wo man dann sozusagen mit jungen mutter
flüchtet ohne geistern ja
nicht mehr vorstellen dass hier nach dem
ja der war bekanntlich eine günstige
richtige reaktion die wir mit mikro die
phänomene mit ja und länder gm bliebe
das hat sich dann entschieden sich mehr
ausschließe und die frau des überlebens
afrika schicken so um die 20 maxi und
bin dann einfach genossen und hat dann
glücklicher wiesenstück buch funde vom
militär und mit aachen krachte mit dem
ausstrahlenden in action zivilisation
vor
1 tag lang sitzt oder zu viert über 900
insektenstich hätte john am schluss kr
reiseerfahrung sich lieber projekt
[Musik]
so
traurig es macht kaiser haben einige das
heroin speer baustelle auf dem bahnhof
in worte business will kleindl haft
wahrscheinlichkeit ist einfach gleich
null und andere nutzer sollte da aber
anders nutzen wir sind grundsätzlich
jäger und sammler wenn ich in keinen
takt der fresse
haut einfach immer sie waren fresse ja
so cool classics hat über haben in der
realität
besser sich auf das konzentrieren wo im
wald wachst seite schon es gibt jede
menge essbare pflanzen
man muss sie nur kleiner und finde
brennessel zum beispiel als fast überall
vitamin und einige die obere sind auf
den jüngsten zeit ist
es fast nichts um steinmeier oder diesen
wirklich sehr zu
wie die fichte gerade im frühling könnt
ihr dort schließlich asse
vitamin c drin richte eine unsere
freunde
die pflanze wo eigentlich schlagkraft
ist die pflanze europa sind und zwar
freund wurzeln dass er da ist die ewige
teufelskralle oder rapunzel klandt
stock oder velo nichtabstieg könnten gar
nicht so herum geschweige denn mit dem
messer jetzt natürlich fatal dass sie
abgerissen aber das macht einfach mal zu
zeigen von désirée ceno die wir bisher
über
bühne direkt aus dem boden
mit wurzeln aus blüte nässe aber
rechnest du wirklich ernsthaft damit
weist das wir alle irgendeinem alliance
rolle als jäger und sammler ist an allen
ecken also praktisch am besten mit allem
und dann passiert das glück kam aber
wenn es passiert dann ist vorbereitet
aber ich meine dass ich jetzt business
auswahltrainer durch das auslegen
vorbereitet sie aber du selber ich
glaube
porzellan nicht näher bekannter in der
stadt betrachten damit dass das system
irgendwann immer so ist wie sie sich wie
immer das wird sie und ich glaube mir
verlangt dann aber einfach eine gern auf
andere sondern lobt dass ich mir selbst
aber ist es nicht so panikmache
nein da reicht auch als profitiere von
der angst nein waren die vorbereiter
schufen problemsituation noch ausständig
entspannen das heißt ich bin viel
ruhiger in einer krisensituation
unterwegs als es importiert das
musical
versorgt
normalerweise würde ich mich erinnere
wasserpfütze wäsche aber wenn der hunger
groß genug ist dass plötzlich herzlich
egal
nicht im wasser zwischen und dann
abreißen sondern waschen und abtrocknen
zwei really not zu sitzen wäre doch
super
also soll die worin das uns als sohn
eines unfairen und abnehmen
nachrüstung zimmer zurück erkennt
[Musik]
und gesprochener super alles immer recht
& noble
[Musik]
während mir sehnsüchtig aufs essen
wartet sind andere schon von 36 hat sich
verzögert da
jetzt komm ich einfach per taxi um jetzt
400 antwortet ist aber los laut
heuer ist dort immer
wieder
zu
hören
besser aber zeigt ein einheimischer
rechte
läuft sieht das
ja du das jetzt auch so faszinierend die
haben mich jetzt sage er
immer und das nachstehende glaube
nicht
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
liter super ist fertig john hat sogar
noch weiter
[Musik]
so
noch 24 stunden ohne essen gibt's
endlich wieder ruhig bis im mai
[Musik]
im sitzen uns für erfahre das thema
überleben der john cho sitz in früher
kindheit beschäftigt
als burg hat er heftig
ein schwieriger mensch sich allgemein
für die sozialen umfeld sehr jähzornig
sie sehr aggressiv hat die mutter immer
wieder schlagen und so und dann hat sich
meine mutter katja dieckow metro jährig
sie sind weil minute hat es willy wimmer
inhaltlich notiert unter telefon und
einem waldtag seite goldmanns ohne gott
den rotsünder strich das militär
stockwerke holland hat vollgeschosse er
hat aber eine truppe wenn man sieht und
mit anlagen in zivil unterwegs zu
bild ich da gestorben
wir sind zusammengewachsen und meine
mutter ist manisch depressiv und das
heißt sie war immer wieder marissa
burgwerben sobald siegen wir sich neben
bewegt hat oder nicht weg kann hat man
nicht einem austausch blüte und dann ist
das ganze puzzle spiel losgeht oder
vertonte sorgen um meine mutter ist nie
überladen zanker und ich habe mich
entscheide weil ich somit der mit der
situation
anderer verbrechen für
sie und nie mehr hilflos jetzt verstehe
ich warum es für ihn so zentral ist dass
man sich selbst ein diktator
[Musik]
und der nächste punkt auf diese weise
programm ist für machen das hat eine
wenige sachen touristischen säugetier
unterscheidet das mit wäre theoretisch
einfach also 14 wochen
ich vermute mal auch schweizer
chemie holzteile braun kürzer und ich
könnte es für mal
anders -
oder respekt und eine stufe darunter das
in der mit funkel raus das sind die
funke stahl wo man quasi mit der sommer
plattling über das metall weniger
getrunken und ein rest von kanal uhr
gibt es noch schnell den kopf wieder weg
also ich schon mal das problem an ich
hoffe es entfachen dass der funke muss
inspirieren erhitze ein großer und
entzünde lausanne immer risch aufs
papier ist ob es der karren wenn ich
also meine mannschaft wird linde relativ
ihm gar nicht sondern es wird sich was
in ihnen
steckt mir fällt
ist ein tempel monat statisches und
jetzige luftiger
ich das ganze auf eine äußere umso
länger brand dann noch heraus
und dank und nichtstun der materialismus
linie und dann kann ich mit meiner
ganzen kleiner funke der den patienten
daran sprich menschen vorteil wenn es
bei frauen oder es ist immer ein vorteil
anfrage wir haben nicht mal meinem konto
wie sie es für mache mit für stahl und
dauer
[Musik]
der film brachte trug unterlag ein
windschutz und will mit
diesen schutz groß
raus kam zum schluss brauchen
mindestens fünf minuten muss für einen
kleinen schnitt bestanden
dass knut material ist und dass frühe
machen und halte es
für richtig bild minuten aber nicht
legst du der moment der wahrheit
der kriminalist orientalische
hersteller
familie sind alle xii positiv sei
reiner zufall
achtung es
brennt aber ich weiß nicht wie lange
hilfe
[Musik]
mit begeisterung haben cool mit der
fahne
der haut des beschlusses auto
nun aber die muss nur zwei minuten
bräunen okay
gut wohnen sekunde
[Applaus]
[Musik]
für challenge bestanden
aber jetzt kommt die wahre kunst im für
macher fühlbare das schafft man nur mit
viel geduld
das königsdisziplin für machen ok
und wenn es selbst an die vita riecht
dann erst abgeschafft und lasse auf
krawall träger du nur solchen stoff dazu
könnte die worte so war jetzt
diskutierte gesellschaftskritik und das
ist unterstrich
zwar die namen nach
[Musik]
hua
das wäre doch
welches probiert
werden es langsam dunkel wird probierte
lukas glück
anderthalb stunden später ist
wirklich nicht
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
ja
[Musik]
sagt richter im survival camp
mit vielen tricks zum überleben er mir
vor allem eins gelernt wer wichtig dass
gruppen ish mieten und gott besser ich
habe gemerkt dass ich
dass ich bei gewissen sachen ja ein
bisschen tollpatschig das mit dem feuer
macht habe ich spreche aber dafür eine
leuten tipps und so und das fand ich
alles also ziemlich schön das war ein
schönes erlebt ist und ich weiß nicht
aber mit mit dem ich dann ins bett
gegangen haben dann gut geschlafen und
heute
ein
[Musik]
mögliches hätte ich gestern gar nicht
gebracht mir würde der kreis steuerte
mit dem
nächsten thema und das kolosse ich für
meine aufgabe über mit dem monierte die
hand pro person 1 liter trinkwasser
finde in der natur der herz
transportieren und dort lager
für die aufgaben der sturm zieht zeit
läuft
[Musik]
vierter machen sich zu 100 prozent
motiviert aber null plan
es frühestens weiß zu suchen
[Musik]
hören sie
denn entdecken plötzlich apple sehr mit
pinsel und wie viel fisch
ganz sicher bin im moment aber zieht
lauf düster und besser passen als gar
keins
so regelmäßig sport auch gar nicht will
muss sie der gedanke so haben das wasser
gesucht gefunden und sind da der bau
dann haben wir doch bessere ideen und
immer das kann aber
die habe relativ lang her und herr
gewährleistet und irgendwann zu gegen
die an die pflanzen kunden aufrecht dass
die extrem viel
talent und dann hat es auch mit
verschiedenen methoden in einer
wasserflasche sammler davidson trick und
das hätte traurig wenn er nachher jeder
trennen das t shirt ist nicht die
einzige möglichkeit wie effektiv wenn du
jetzt mit mit textil zum beispiel mit
dem holz durch über diese gerade wer
schnell die antalya auf schienen aus
seeste darüber nun gemacht sie sind
hätte darin steckt viel drüber ziehen
über das große ringe und geräte direkt
ins wasser ich hoffe dass die jungs
probiert ob das wageninnere stunde
sonnenlicht wasser herausbringen locker
du hast was der kunde
also seines sonne führt sondern wie es
sich gehört so eine fürchterliche wo es
ein abfluss hat was muss läuft etwas
läuft haben wir ein paar wackler und
nein denkt das wäre mir jetzt wohl alles
wasser was für ober- und ist direkt im
sport das ist lagen schnee
sobald wasser erde berührt hat ist
wahrscheinlichkeit dass bakterien
könnten sie frühestens klasse mit
trinkwasser und sumpfgebiet ist bakterie
pur
[Gelächter]
wichtig ist dass er wasser gefunden hat
kann ich es ja noch aufbereitet und dann
zeigt dies die john überraschende
trinkwasser abkochen kamen sogar in
einer pet-flasche
stellen das wasser fragte zu hoch ob
jetzt zwei minuten funktioniert
tatsächlich
ich habe nur vier absoluten opfer als
empfehlen
das ist dieser weg sie von joan miró mit
ist es kein
festes spitzley wehmütig obwohl
saaleufer dusche und pressefreiheit
wirklich messer mit besten
als die
cops in zweifel und was nimmst du mit
musste im buch genannt extrem viel also
ich gemerkt am anfang bin ich mit neben
dem vorbehalt gestartet aber ich habe so
viel platz also ganz mies fazit ich habe
dort nicht ob es für krisen und
notsituationen client sondern es lieber
[Musik]
deftig
gäste dann hier in ein ganz neues video
[Gelächter]
wünsche alles gut die hofer mit mir in
der sie war situation und waren den
höchsten rätselhaft und müsli glaube
durch so
ein endlich habe ich die zivilisation
genieße
[Musik]
ihr rechter arm linie die nicht für
möglich halten und trotzdem einen
schnellzug molina situation nicht
erwähnt dass man muss mit dem
aufsammeln und ich bin gespannt wen ihr
gesehen das hätte die boxen selber alles
machen und bin dass generell sind wohl
dass man sich vorbereitet durch krisen
und notsituationen
kommentar